but I was licking all over that beging
away did it taste funny did it taste
like metal I was so horny here the worst
part here's the worst part right sensing
a theme we finish whatever
[Music]
philanthropic everybody be honest okay
what is the worst sex you ever had oh I
have a lot and it doesn't have to mean
that a bad thing happened like what
happened to me just worse is it could
have been mediocre it could have been
like a you know a bad time
you performed badly if you don't have
like a memory of it does that mean that
like you're you're bad that's what I was
going to say probably the story of all
the women oh my God that's what I to say
you were yeah I have one very clear
moment let's hear it so um I think when
I was 15 and 16 I was doing crazy
ecstasy every [__] day and if any of
you guys have ever tried it when you
take ecstasy your dick [__] shrinks
into like this pen I don't know why
but it [__] like balls up into the
[__] hardest smallest thing you've
ever seen in your life that's what it
does it shrinks it's like a collapsing
star yeah like a [__] like it's
getting vacuum sealed into like into
[__] a kidney stone but it's hard you
easy easy it's like a it's like a
[__] turtle head going back into a
shell that's all you hard how come it's
hard I think cuz it's getting
condensed like that
yeah make a face and [__] um there
was this girl that I we really liked and
she just got our relation I just got our
relationships we're trying to take it
slow and then I remember the night that
uh I felt like it was going to go down I
was like really really happy cuz I was
super into her she was super into me and
I haven't used um my dick in a
while why I don't remember why because I
did just get out of relationship but I
don't remember why sometimes you just
don't use your dick it's a funny way of
putting it use it all the time but the
part that the part that's a clear memory
was I remember when we're going to do it
I put it in feels crazy good and then I
literally nut in a second like a second
that sounds like a dream come true
that's no it feel it was because there's
so much buildup it was one of those
things where like I didn't even drive
yet so my homie had to drive my homie
I'm like oh sh I think it's going to go
down so my homie is going to help me go
pick up condoms so he was like so it's
like you know when you're a kid it takes
so much forking uh much orchestrating to
get things to happen cuzz you don't have
a car so he takes me to get condoms then
we go downstairs I'm watching TV I go
upstairs I'm like hey I think it's going
to go down he was like [__] it's [__]
like 11:00 or 12 at night I'm just just
knock out on the couch so it's like this
whole thing that my homie is supporting
me to make this happen and then I go
upstairs and then it happens and then I
literally come downstairs [__] like 2
minutes later you did you let yourself
and your friend down I think I let
myself down I let her down
and then even I was like you let him
down yeah let him down I was record was
pissed I don't even know what happened
it was just like so like the whole film
set yeah it just felt so like I didn't
even know what the [__] happened it was
crazy oh no why did you just go again I
don't I'm not a go again just go again
bro go again you need to take for you to
go again also on ecstasy though like
again I also wasn't even on Ecstasy but
I think I did so much it stayed with me
oh residual ecstasy mess you up yeah and
then and then because you came so fast
that it's so like abrupt and shocking
sucks that you just kind of wish like
someone could go Abracadabra and it
could disappear yeah but you can't you
got to still got to go like oh what was
that
who oh yeah so you got to figure out a
way to like all right next
we you need an exit strategy what is
that exit yeah there's still got to be
you still got to exit I'll tell you what
the exit is you go man this has
literally never happened to me before
your [__] is just so [__] bomb got
to get used to this but even when you
say that you feel like ah what what her
reaction like what did she say to you
she was sweet and she was just like oh
like that was awesome or whatever and
she was like just being really like oh
my God you had an Angel that's terrible
that's sweet what happened is it
happened
again too good and the second time she
said again and I was
like oh got to go wanted to [__] open
the window [__]
just I was like what the [__] is going
on were you on exy the second time I
wasn't even on EX on any of the times
but I just did so much I don't know what
happened my [__] penis broke or
something wow damn damn did you survive
more than one pump next time yeah how's
it now you got it under control yeah now
it's regular but that was like now he
survives 10 pumps no but that one was
like the second time was 4X maybe maybe
less than like five pumps crazy yeah did
you have another time after that or that
was a I think I started taking more
ecstasy and Ras half my brain I don't
remember so you just went full ecstasy
mode so you never saw this chick again
after the second no we still we're da
like we're actually together together
they're married now we did so we
actually I mean we did you have other
more Redemption times I don't even
remember my brain got fried damn that's
a so this is our most disappointing SE
to stories right but then that one I it
was a it was clear memory of what
happened I remember my clothes that I
was wearing I remember my friend I was
laying on the couch I remember his car
because it was so like how embarrassing
yeah damn it's pretty rough so doozy
hearing a girl say again pretty hard
[__] [__] that's that's honest even
even when they try to comfort you it's
okay I'm fine and they do that you're go
would you rather hear that or oh my gosh
that's
adorable ooh
what's the
context are we [__] both times
they're just looking at your dick that
that'll make me sad yeah as if it's a
Furby yeah yeah and they just put their
nose on it oh Gucci Gucci goo oh so cute
jeez I don't know if I had bad sex
because if I get to come it's pretty
nice so no matter how bad it is for you
still a dub yeah no matter how bad it is
like I get to finish accompl and I'm
like a it's not so bad after all right
but I do remember feeling
like
disgusted and I went through with it
anyway sometimes there's moments where
I'm just so horny that I do regretful
things like I remember one clear picture
of doing it with this girl and I'm
licking on her ear she's [__] got a
ear infection from the from the earrings
what that's worst case scenario I was
licking all all over that [__] [__]
beging away did it taste funny did it
taste like metal I was so horny but here
the worst part here's the worst part
right sensing a theme we finished
whatever
philanthropic I'm [__] sick like so
sick for like a week just vomiting oh
Noe [__] T you got you're licking her
blood you got physically ill I got
[__] ill bro I was vomiting orange
and like I was dying dude and my mom was
like oh you got AIDS you're [__] with
the wrong girls and [__] I'm like it's
not AIDS it was ears I promise she had
an ear infection I probably drank ear
infection dude the infection didn't like
not turn you it didn't turn you off I
think when I it's like you know how some
people see red when they're mad yeah I
see pink when I'm horny and it just goes
that's love baby it just turns me into a
person where after I come I'm like why
that is so
gross if if Joe was a sexual stock I
would
sell it's funny cuz you didn't even have
to lick her ear I didn't licking in the
ear is like that's a elective I scoop
the bottom and I can still get out but I
don't know that's interesting yeah there
are moments where I think like man
blacks out when he's fing it you're just
so horny that you're doing certain
things but like things that don't even
feel good I'm like why you don't care
you have one sexy story just one well
it's the funniest stuff that I I know I
know but you have a sexy story for us
I'm not going to tell palette I'm
palette the room full of guys I'm not
going to tell you I'm tell you I was
drinking so I was drinking like a bunch
of ear fluid I'm not going to tell you
guys a good
story I was drinking an ear infection
like gallons of an ear infection I'm not
telling you guys like can I just get one
SE just give me something to Cle cleanse
the ballet I know we need a success
story please come on I need like the
[__] ginger man
yeah Ginger the sushi any Ginger I've
been in weird situations where I'm like
you like that okay that you were against
no what girl was like oh can you put on
some dep pens diaper you said yes to
that just a what think just of course he
did you got depends on you like that
though like Joe had it in his trunk
grandparents what's a Depends diaper
what's it's like an adult diaper it's
like for adults that sh I get I was
trying to get a comes with Activia too
it's like elderly people
dude I got a depend diaper so what
happens after I was wear a real crinkly
diaper what happens is fetish [__]
wets up yeah but like do you have to
play the role of like a baby or
something yeah he's got to put his thumb
in his mouth she got to clean up that
diapy he's like no I just wore the
diaper I didn't play
the I just put it on and went to sleep
dude Jo's like a Joe's like a lazy
Community Theater he put the costume on
and then he he fed it in even read his
lines
I'm like a kid working at a pizza store
and then it's like all right it's your
turn to [__] be in the costume and
I'm like [__] all right got to go fly
the sign outside you wore adult diapers
that's pretty [__] cool there's one
that was living on the edge another one
another one there was one that I was
like this is this is crossing the line
which looking back I probably should
have done it this is crossing the line
she wanted me to wear the uncle chin
outfit that's not C on brand that's I
should have done that yeah and then act
the Uncle chin did that make you feel
uncomfortable when she asked you why'
you say no yeah why' you say no I think
it was too sacred cuz I'm like this is
my you think of Bart character I'm like
no this is like my YouTube character
I'll do I'll do I'll put on a [__]
diaper but I ain't going to put on this
thing I'll let you carry me like a baby
I'll let your dirty ass ear but I put
that on why you put me in a song and
I'll breastfeed for you but I'm not
going to do that fuing I'll go to urgent
care for a week but go lay in the
incubator yeah I'll drink your ear
infection but I'll get my stomach pumped
after this but that's about it I like
your priorities bro they're pretty cool
it's really good you are a giver huh
anyone else got any any FS bad stories
so I got a a pretty we're talking about
our worst ones right yeah sure yeah I'll
just say we were super drunk one time
it's like long time ago and you know
sometimes when you're like super drunk
uh things get like really rough like
you're just more down for rough it's not
like Central it's a lot more just
[__] ground pound like like crazy
right you her home girl was like super
rough and super rough to the point where
like it was like it was hurting me a lot
oh [__] but at the same time I'm drunk
too and I'm trying to like man up to it
what was she doing days what was she
riding just the method it was not smooth
there was no momentum upper cutting your
nuts he was honestly rough she was you
like that [__] [__] was she on top it
was all all all which ways all which
ways she was throwing that thing back
most of it was she was on top I see okay
and maybe rough's not the right word
because rough maybe still implies like
oh it rough no this is like painful she
wasn't slapping your face or not no not
like that not like she's like I have a
par particular set of
skill h on we make you feel very
un she was just hammering like way too
hard okay same time I was drunk too and
I wasn't trying to be like yo this hurts
in my dumbass nature I was just trying
to take it trying to hang with it okay
yeah trying to keep up um
sure but at the same time you try to
match her also when when you're drunk
you can like last longer so this just
this was a long period like very don't
make that noise dude since you can't
tell us can you act
like yes it was very hard it got to the
point though that sounds like it hurts
it was very painful by the time I pulled
up and uh pulled out and
busted there was blood that came out
sh you dude you're hardcore baby from
you where did you RI where was you RI
where were you
ripped she [__] you so hard your I
don't know
internally she broke was it just dry
you're not a virgin
anymore you lost it there yeah my hman
broke obviously maybe she was diaper
after she probably was oh yeah maybe it
bursted a blood vess it hurt and I'll
sore for like 2 days after that sh
you're a gangster bro thanks for
oversharing hey dude [__] salute dude
SI I edit delete that whole
thing Anthony let's go dude a giver
through and through mine's pretty quick
it was I was with the chick yeah thank
you very much I was with a chick and I
had her bent over and all that kind of
beautiful things beautiful things and
then but then I had the unmistakable
smell of as Jo cow would say Kaka oh oh
no you SM she [__] smell the cocka what
the [__] I honestly think that she might
maybe had a Mis wiping incident oh no
where it was like that happen maybe
perhap some residual some
residual honestly like I was pretty
proud of myself cuz I kept going for
like at least I don't know probably 3
minutes after that do that sometimes
just like this I just breathe out of my
mouth maybe I was just trying to figure
it out I I I didn't place the blame yet
I was just so confused was your own
butthole it clearly wasn't cuz my
butthole was all the way back there
imagine going I know it's me it's me my
bad don't me it happens sometimes cuz
then when she when it was a hot day and
you and it you freshly peel off her
[__] pants and stuff and then you get
a wolf of it that happens that happens
and and it did happen and um yeah it was
very confusing and for me I was just
like damn I cannot continue with this so
I just pretended like I couldn't keep
going oh wow you try to flip her on her
back or something your own male failure
to get out of this he still has a boner
too he's like I can't keep doing this
I'm sorry basically she didn't smell the
[__] how would she I think it's harder
to smell well cuz she's in doggy style
if it's normal to her then had her bent
over is what he said did that Crush her
though some girls get crushed by that
you don't tell I tell her bro what the
[__] are you talking about did you
pretend that's barwan by the way he's
like barad's like I can't keep going and
he's like your butt smells like [__] no
I mean I mean you say you can't keep
going some girls are like wait I don't
turn you on yeah let's say something
like that you figure out some
alternative dialogue always that's
happened yeah you take the blame you
take the L right you [__] go down
right you're the president's man you're
like guess what dude it was me dude I
had all the files and my locker and [__]
I'm I'm going down right I would have
pretend you don't bwan this [__] yeah
you don't blame no no but girls I'm G
Gordon litty dude I'm going down for the
crime yeah like girls will still put it
on themselves that's true that's why you
got go I Came yeah all done I didn't do
that I'm
finished oh I'm so sleepy she's like
what are you Steph [__] Hawking all
of a sudden what's you go ah and you're
like oh not a lot of sperm came out cuz
I came earlier today
yeah why Nar you masturbated earlier
right everything you say just requires
more
questions just so you know I'm a real
dribbler if I if I masturbate earlier I
dribble all the time dribbler oh God I'm
double dribbler yeah just so you know I
feel like yours couldn't have all been
perfect no well dude I have terrible
performances a lot of the
time and it's usually but because I've
been with my girl for so long it's very
like you know very safe space Oh okay
just be like it's okay and I'll just be
sobbing a little bit she's like it's
okay sobbing no but usually for me it's
always like Nick is always a crier it's
always popping dude popping a little
early or not doing feeling like you
didn't do enough I don't think there's
there's any embarrassment from coming
too fast I don't think that's a bad
thing I to me I let myself down dude cuz
you're trying to you're trying to stay
in the pocket and you're trying to
control your breathing and then
sometimes you just can't sometimes it
just goes you know you want them to feel
good too yeah yeah of course you want to
you want to be able to hold a note but
sometimes they eat her [__] yeah dude
obviously but sometimes you just if you
care so bad yeah obviously obviously you
[__] Munch The Box dude but you know
it's like sometimes you're just or be a
man and just come and go to sleep oh
dude cramping while you're love making
is kind of really embarrassing cramp oh
hell yeah cramping is embarrassing
you're the one laying down you're not
doing [__] like what the [__] I got to
drink a whole [__] Gatorade before I
go again but you know it's just like and
your toes go like this and you're like
ah godamn or your calf you know how
about when the Pandora commercials come
on oh yeah we let them run we love it
you cheap ass why don't you have premium
no dude when when it's too hot I'm I'm
dead I'm dead it's over [__] you I don't
care too hot that's your Bane I run hot
already if it's too hot I'm out oh you
know what sucks what what throws me out
too is when I start sweating a lot and I
feel self-conscious even in like
Jiu-Jitsu and I'm going to relate sex to
Jiu-Jitsu okay when I'm rolling with my
buds we're rolling with our Buds and I'm
just like say if Joe's teaching class or
something and I [__] I drip on him I
feel awful I feel terrible you're nice
really yeah yeah but it's like it's part
of it right after you drip on him he
takes you and he throws you down and he
drips on you and then just [__] then
I'm a I'm a c you never use sweat block
what's that it's you just wipe it on the
spots that you sweat and it won't sweat
really that's [__] czy okay so
sometimes when you're when you're love
making and then you sweat too much it it
pulls me out the same way it gets oh you
get he about it and you just you're just
like ah like I'm sorry you know what I
mean like you just feel like I'm and I
sweat when I sweat I'm like I'm I'm a
moist boy I watched a bead of [__]
sweat go for my nose to like Nikki's
forehead and I was like I'm out
yeah hey you're put in some work though
that's good oh I always put in the work
dude I'm a [__] Nikki's an exercise
machine basically you know it's on
mechine bring a towel with you yeah dude
I [__] you a personal trainer like
get that [__] come on baby bottle of
water 2 minutes faster than your last
one more ref but like yeah for that I
was like this is [__] up and I love
look I like humiliating that [__] I do
but that was just to nothing this is
gross the sweat yeah you just feel bad I
I feel bad at least you know it's always
a really hard thing to recover from
maybe you guys have a tactic for this
but like when you make the the sound
when you fart not when you fart the dick
in the [__] puts it put in the weird
they make the sound we don't do it when
you make but and I say that's on you
that's that's on
you that's what I say you [__] what you
did that but it's hard to like laugh cuz
I mean like sometimes you have the
dynamic where you can laugh and like
nothing gets interrupted but then like
other times you don't know what to do
it's kind of sometimes you make that
sound because it's the angle and pushed
air in I try to make that sound as much
as
possible let me find that angle again
he's trying to make it happen it's so
comfortable for her too she loves
that they love
it